I mean ever since I was a kid I've been
fascinated with the universe and of
course not knowing nearly as much as I
would have wanted to know so invent the
cosmos I I took this metaphoric notion
of black holes because I find them so
interesting and I say metaphor because
it's of course about different things
about humans and about our searches and
feelings this is Anna full of Elster
she's an Icelandic composer who wrote
the piece of music that you're hearing
meta cosmos meta cosmos is receiving its
UK premiere this month at the Proms the
piece is inspired by the idea of falling
into a black hole of surrendering to an
utterly powerful object that you just
can't resist now writing music about
falling into a black hole is actually
pretty hard because the scientific
answer to the question what would it
sound like if you fell into a black hole
is well
even if you allowed for a medium that
sound could travel through so it's not
just vacuum then the answer is still
pretty boring if kind of funny if you
were to totally understandably scream a
constant pitch as you got closer and
closer to a black hole then the space
that you occupy gets smaller and smaller
and smaller the closer you get at least
radially away from the black hole that
means that as a sound wave that you
create propagates towards some observer
far away it starts to occupy
increasingly larger and larger space but
it contains the same amount of energy so
it gets red shifted to lower frequencies
the closer you get to a black hole the
more redshifted your sound becomes or in
other words to a distant observer it
would sound like a large more
interesting question then is what would
it feel like if you fell into a black
hole and that's where science meets art
this year is the 50th anniversary of the
Apollo 11 landing and so to celebrate
the BBC Proms is hosting a variety of
music inspired by science and
particularly by space that includes
Anna's Mehta cosmos and fortunately for
us audience members Anna isn't only
drawing inspiration from the equations
of general relativity I don't think I
can ever even say that I ever studied
science I guess like when you're when
you're in school you you have to study
some things and that I did of course but
I haven't studied science at all
although not using equations I'm using
the ideas that the equations project
right so in that sense I'm really using
that inspiration but some composers and
some artists would actually be very
interested in taking the exact equations
and then applying them into musical
terms and present path and this emphasis
on feeling over rigor over equations is
exemplified by Anna's sketches that she
does before she composes a piece so
initially when I'm writing music I spend
a lot of time you know finding the piece
and this process can take varies months
of time but it's a very good mnemonic
device for me to
draw out the graphic Li the process of
the piece the structure and the elements
that are present within the music so the
so the image then represents the
structure for the piece and the kind of
details within that structure for
example with meta cosmos the the graphic
drawing that I did initially the sketch
it also has all the pictures like a
harmonic progression indicated at the
bottom and then the overall graphic
structure so it incorporates these
things that I can then remember and
listen to the picture as I'm writing
with music into notation now this is
actually very similar to how some
scientific ideas are born I remember in
my PhD thesis before rigorously deriving
the equations that I needed I did a
graphical sketch of what the theory
looked like of some key facts maybe a
couple of key equations but a sketch of
graphically what I was trying to do and
the crossover between science and art
doesn't just stop there the end of
method cosmos consists of strings yes
and owing higher and higher and higher
and the tension builds as all control is
lost to the black hole
[Music]
and that very much reminded me of what
happens to space-time around a
singularity when you get closer to a
black hole space gets compressed so that
to me was what the sound of that would
be it was it would be strings getting
taller and taller and tall so that's
beautiful I mean actually yeah that's a
really nice thing to hear because you
know in fact that's not something I was
thinking about consciously but things
happen either in subconscious out or you
know hearing you talk about it it makes
makes sense to me meeting Anna was an
amazing experience in seeing how science
and art tackled different problems in
different ways but sometimes they
actually tackle a problem in the same
way and sometimes they even come up with
the same answer if you'd like to hear
this fascinating blend of science and
music for yourself then you can do so in
person on the 22nd of July when it
receives its UK premiere at the Royal
Albert Hall and if you can't make it
there in person then you can listen live
on BBC Radio 3 more information down
there in the links in the description
this wasn't actually a sponsored video I
should probably put a disclaimer here
the BBC just got in touch and said would
I be interested in making a video with
Anna and to talk about her music and
maybe go and see a few proms and that's
an amazing opportunity so obviously I
said yes so thank you BBC for reaching
out thank you Anna for your time it was
wonderful to interview you this is my
first prom season so I'm really really
excited to come and see some of the
concerts let me know what you thought of
me blending science and music for this
channels content down in the comments
I'd be really interested know what you
think's if you like it I'd like to do
more pop the video a like and a share if
you enjoyed it and thank you so much for
watching I'll see in the next one